but what we have found at least in in
our scientific studies is that that
prefrontal cortex region that we spoke
about before that sort of rational
logical mud of the brain that's one of
the first things to go when you're
sleep-deprived so that area of the brain
just gets sort of switched off right the
more that you are sort of lacking in
your sleep
an emotional deep emotional centers of
the brain which are normally controlled
and kept in check by that prefrontal
cortex they just erupt in terms of their
activity so you're all emotional gas
pedal into little regulatory control
brake which for the most part very bad
but you know one possibility is that if
you want to try and get a little bit
sort of you know crazy loosey-goosey you
know maybe that's not bad for that type
of sort of comedic writing that you you
know you become a bit more childlike and
yeah I say that affectionately because
the last part of the brain to mature in
development is the prefrontal cortex so
you revert back to almost a more
childlike state but I wouldn't I
honestly would not condone that sort of
you know undergoing sleep just based on
the mortality and you know risk of
Alzheimer's and cancer by itself you
just don't want to understand in short
doses like give a couple days a week
like here's the if sleep is not a
renewable resource like what is the
effect of say if you have three nights a
week where you sleep eight hours and
then the next night two hours and then
the next night eight hours how much of a
bump or how much of a dip does that two
hours give you in your overall health
it's bad it's bad so I'll give you two
examples that there's a study where they
just took individuals and they just gave
him four hours of sleep for one night
and what they saw was a 70% reduction in
critical anti cancer fighting immune
cells called natural killer cells these
are wonderful immune assassins that
target malignant cells so today both you
and I have produced cancer cells in our
body what prevents those cancer cells
from becoming the disease that we call
cancer is in part these natural killer
cells
and after one night of four hours of
sleep that is a remarkable state of
immune-deficiency and that's one of the
reasons why insufficient sleep predicts
cancer I could also speak about your
cardiovascular system though and all it
takes is one hour because there is a
global experiment that's performed on
1.6 billion people across 70 countries
twice a year and it's called daylight
savings time hmm now in the spring when
we lose an hour of sleep we see a
subsequent 24 percent increase in heart
attacks what in the fall in the autumn
when we gain an hour of sleep there's a
21 percent decrease in heart attacks so
it's bi-directional that's how fragile
and vulnerable
your body is to even just the smallest
perturbation of sleep an hour one hour
yeah Wow
that is you're blowing my [ __ ] mind
it's Friday I mean you can go even
further by the way you know Wow
insufficient sleep will even erode the
very fabric of biological life itself
your DNA code so in one study they took
a group of healthy adults and they
limited them to six hours of sleep for
one week and they compared the profile
of gene activity relative to when those
same people were getting eight hours of
sleep and there were two critical
results the first was that a sizeable
711 genes were distorted in their
activity caused by one week of six hours
of sleep which is highly relevant by the
way because we know that many people are
trying to survive on six hours of sleep
during the week Wow
this is second sorry no please go I was
gonna say the second sort of perhaps
more interesting result was that about
half of those genes were actually
increased in their activity the other
half were actually suppressed those
genes that were switched off by six
hours of sleep for a week were genes
related to your immune response many of
them so you become immune deficient
those genes that were increased or what
we call overexpressed were genes that
were related to the promotion of tumors
genes that were related to long term
chronic inflammation within the body and
genes that were associated with stress
and as a consequence cardiovascular
disease
this is unbelievable